r l'equilibre politique de la région
n'est donc pas rompu mais le ps apparaît
comme le grand battu certaines
personnalités en font les frais claude
bartolone
mais surtout le jeune sénateur jean luc
mélenchon il a été battu d'un cheveu à
massy par l'udf vincent delahaye
deux raisons à cette défaite le projet
de la gare tgv qu'il boucle qui
bouleverse la ville mais surtout le
maintien du candidat génération écologie
voyez le reportage de christine kelly
yvon godin sur la soirée d'hier une
soirée pleine d'amertume
voilà où débat depuis par nous mêmes par
la division qu'est ce que vous voulez
passer de gueule la bataille continue à
bien des hauts et des bas va là s'il bat
quoi tu as perdu de son sens 13 ou
anormalement nous sommes treize rendez
compte
génération écologie ça s'appelle sam
si maintenant la mode c'est de se
maintenir dès qu'on a 10 % des voix quoi
qu'il arrive il n'y aura plus un seul
élu de gauche dans ce pays et donc il
est temps de dénoncer le pseudo discours
moral de ceux qui disent qu'il faut se
maintenir en toutes circonstances c'est
absolument une morale puisque ça a
abouti à ce résultat que dans un canton
de gauche avec une large majorité de
gauche
c'est un homme de droite qui était lui
toujours
mais moi le nom dont milad parti
socialiste a perdu je n'estime pas de
nom peut perdre la gauche
les valeurs que nous avons défendues
sont bien identifiés à massy comme étant
des gens de gauche
nous estimons que je qui avait peut-être
été sanctionné là ce sont les pratiques
politiques notamment où l'absence de
pratiques concrètes locale un profit si
ces élections de l'automne et sur
cantona c'est ces pratiques à la fois
politique et l'élu local qui ont été
sanctionnées si effectivement la
majorité la majorité c'est à dire le
parti socialiste considère que la
conséquence de ça c'est de nous retirer
une obligation c'est de nous est chère
majorité c'est sa responsabilité
ceci ne viendra pas de nous ce baptême
du feu oui j'ai 32 ans donc je suis
jeune
bon je me battais contrat sénateur qui a
quand même une image nationale n'était
pas facile donc je suis effectivement
très content d'avoir réussi à gagner
cette élection même si les ter n'est pas
n'est pas très sensible